باريس سان جيرمان يعاقب ميسي هل بسبب
زيارته الى السعوديه
عقب اللعب ليونيل ميسي مهاجمه باريس سان
جيرمان بالايقاف لمده اسبوعين بسبب سفره
من دون الحصول على اذن الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه حسب ما ذكرت صحيفه ليكي
بالرياضيه الفرنسيه واشار تقرير الصحيفه
الى ان اللاعب الارجنتيني الفائز بكاس
العالم ممنوع من اللعب او التدريب مع سان
جيرمان كما سيخصم الفريق اجره خلال فتره
الايقاف وسيغيب ميسي الذي يبلغ من العمر
35 عاما عن المبارتين المقبلتين في دوري
الدرجه الاولى الفرنسيه امام ترويج اكسيو
لكنه قد يعود للمباراه ضد اوكسير في
الحادي والعشرين من مايو الجاري
وجاءت رحله ميسي للمملكه بعد هزيمه النادي
الباريسي وذكر التقارير صحفيه ايضا الى ان
ميسي طلب بالفعل ابنا من النادي للسفر الى
السعوديه للقيام باعمال تجاريه حيث يتولى
منصب السفير السياحه المحليه في المملكه
لكن طلبه قبل بالربط فسافر من دون علم
النادي وظهر ميسي مع عائلته يوم امس
الثلاثاء في مدينه الدرعيه التاريخيه كما
التقط له صور في حي الطريف الشهير وهو
محاط باطفاله ورجال بزي الشعبي للمنطقه
وكتب احمد الخطيب وزير السياحه السعوديه
على تويتر اهلا ميسي في ارض العراقه واصل
التاريخ الدرعيه في جوله سياحيه ممتعه
تضمنت تجارب ومتنوعه مع زوجته وابنائه حيث
التقى بالشعب السعودي الكريم المضياف في
حيطرف
[موسيقى]